Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, du warst doch beim Rechtsausschuss, wie wie es, wie ist das gelaufen.
Ja, also entgegen der konstant negativen Berichterpfeffer.
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer zwo zwo drei und äh gegen der allgemeinen Darstellung äh war das eine eine sehr erfolgreiche Auftritt folgen Herr Neumann. Äh.
Ja. Don beliebte Fake News.
Die Presse ist äh weltweit äh in Begeisterungsstürmer äh.
Eingetaucht und und hat diese hat diesen Tag einfach als historisch äh gelobt. Ja. Prost und Pross und Pressesprecher eigentlich.
Ich habe das, ich habe Historisches geschafft. Tatsächlich, also das hätte hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass ich das schaffe. Wir haben.
Die Einladung doch am Mittwoch, den einunddreißigsten fünften im äh Rechtsausschuss als Sachverständiger zum Staatstrojaner äh aufzutreten, erreichte mich äh am Montag den neunundzwanzigsten.
Beim Mittagessen und ähm ja, ich habe das dann äh geschafft, noch eine Stellungnahme zu schreiben, die war am Dienst Dienstag Nacht fertig, noch ähm Unterstützung gehabt von Konstanze Kurz und Frank Krieger.
Und ähm.
Warum ist denn das bitte so kurzfristig.
Ja, also der.
Da geht's auch nur um die Zukunft der Menschheit und so.
Da geht's nur um die Zukunft der Menschheit. Ich also man kriegt ja viele, also es gibt, es gibt einen Grund dafür. Es gibt eine, es gibt eine Reihe an Gründen dafür
die mit Gesundheitlichen Problemen von Mitarbeitern, von Abgeordneten und dann guckt der eine nicht beim anderen auf den Schreibtisch und,
Der eine war krank und huch.
Gleich Juni.
Sowas passiert halt mal. Ja.
Dann haben wir eher den Eindruck, es passiert laufend.
Das äh ja, das passiert natürlich auch. Also wenn ich wenn wenn CC
bin als Vertreter des CC zum Staatstrianer gehört wirst, dann wirst du nicht von der Regierungskoalition bestellt,
dann wirst du von der äh Opposition geholt. Und wenn man sich mal anschaut, was die, was die Regierungskoalition gerade noch so an an Gesetzen durchballert, ne
dann kann man sich natürlich schon auch vorstellen, dass die Koalition, äh dass die äh Opposition gerade ganz schön am Straucheln ist
Die kriegen den Pflichtet einfach gerade rechts und links um alle Ohren. Ne, man hätte sich jemand fragt sich ja irgendwie, was die letzten,
vier Jahre eigentlich oder die letzten drei Jahre passiert ist in der Regierung, dass den jetzt auf einmal noch dieser ganze Mist einfällt.
Und man hat so ein bisschen den Eindruck ähm.
Ohne jetzt, also da den kann man ja auch von außen schon bekommen, dass sie einfach gerade die, die Opposition gerade einfach mal überrennen, ne?
Die waren ja auch gut beschäftigt mit ihren und also den Untersuchungsausschüssen und so weiter,
Und irgendwann muss er dann nochmal kurz regieren und warum nicht einfach kurz vor Schluss? Hasse immer ein Argument der Eile,
prügelt sie mal schnell alles durch und dann lässt du deine Opposition die gerade noch irgendwie im,
mit der Aufarbeitung des NS Auer natürlich beschäftigt ist äh einfach mal gut vor die Wand rennen, ne? Kannst du dir auch vorstellen, also die,
Regierungskoalition ist ja den sieht ja in den meisten Dingen,
Keine Probleme in diesem NSA, ne? Das ist ja, da ist ja jetzt nichts weltbewegendes aufgedeckt worden, was man nicht schon längst durch die Gesetzesnovellen inzwischen legalisiert hätte.
Mhm.
Und wie geht dieses schöne äh Öttinger Vibinger Zitat? Äh Günther Öttinger am Grabe von Hans Vilbinger,
dem Nazi-Richter, was damals recht war, kann heute nicht Unrecht sein. Haben sie auch gemacht, haben sie auch für gesorgt, ja? Ähm,
Na ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ist aber eigentlich in diesem Fall so ein bisschen anders, ne? Sowas damals Unrecht, da äh war.
Muss heute recht sein.
Heute recht sein.
Was damals unrecht war, muss heute recht sein, ja. Stimmt, wir sind beide noch so ein bisschen auf dem Schlauch heute Morgen. Ähm genau, aber äh die wenn man die.
Opposition.
Und die Mitarbeiter der Opposition, die äh die Mitarbeiter der Oppositionspolitiker, die im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss sind, die sind ja gerade mit den vielen tausend Seiten NS Auer Abschlussb,
beschäftigt, ne? Und die zanken sich natürlich um jedes einzelne Wort da drin, kann man sich ja vorstellen, ne? Koalition sagt alles gut, hier gibt's hier gibt's nichts zu sehen, gehen sie weiter.
Opposition sagt, Skandalskandal, Skandal.
Skandal hier Skandal und dann sagen die ja dann schreib und dann schreiben die und dann sagen die, ne das wollen wir aber nicht, ne? So und durch die,
die Regierungsvertreter oder die Regierungskoalition hat natürlich sehr viel mehr Mitarbeiter für dieses für diesen ganzen Cinova.
Als äh die Opposition zur Verfügung hat, ne? Ähm das sieht man ja allein schon daran, dass Patrick Sensburg in der Lage war jetzt schon,
Ein Buch über seinen Vorsitz des NSA zu veröffentlichen. Ja, was ähm was er irgendwie von einem Ghostwriter hat, schreiben lassen
wo man jetzt irgendwie sagen kann, der man wenn der Mann die Zeit hat äh oder das Geld ne, dann ist es natürlich Recht, sein Recht das zu tun und andere Leute haben auch Bücher geschrieben, Gutenberg hat eine ganze Doktorarbeit schreiben lassen, insofern,
Ne, das kannst du machen. Aber das ist halt stilos, ne? Das ist äh insbesondere, wenn du der Ausschuss Vorsitzende bist,
stilos, ähm, weil du damit die Deutungshoheit über die Ergebnisse des Ausschusses an dich reist, bevor der Ausschuss zu einem Ergebnis gekommen ist. Und das ist ähm geschmacklos und stillos
also das ist alles, was man dazu kann er machen, ist ein freies Land, ja? Kann sich jeder so Scheiße auffüllen, wie er möchte, aber das zeugt einfach von einer
von einer Missachtung des Gremiums, dem er da vorgesessen hat, ja? Und das muss man einfach mal so zur Kenntnis nehmen,
das ist ekelig, das so zu machen.
Abgesehen davon, dass er natürlich auch irgendwie dann Atominem geht in diesem Buch, aber lassen wir das. Lassen wir das. Ich ich schweife schon wieder ab. Genau, also die diejenigen, die arbeiten im Bundestag sind damit beschäftigt, ähm.
Die ganzen Untersuchungsausschüsse irgendwie zum Ende zu bringen. Untersuchungsausschüsse sind 'ne Heidenarbeit und so kommt es dann dummerweise grade zu,
Ressourcenengpässen in den Fraktionen. Ich bin derjenige, der das dann ausbaden musste.
Ärgerlich, aber ähm ich wollt's zumindest die Zusammenhänge dann auch erklären bevor ich jetzt hier rumrante.
Dass ich in anderthalb Tagen ähm am Ende zwanzig Seiten Stellungnahme geschrieben habe. Das war auch echt äh geil. Also ich war, ich weiß nicht, Frank und Konstanz haben wie gesagt unterstützt, aber der,
achtzig, neunzig Prozent der der Texte waren nachher im Pad, in meiner Farbe,
Ist ja auch klar, dann kannst du muss ja irgendwie das muss er auch erstmal hinkriegen, dass du spontan die Zeit hast, ne? War also war Glück, ne, hätte genauso gut jemand anders. War Glück oder Pech, dass ich die Zeit hatte.
Jetzt auch gerade irgendwo wieder unterwegs sein können.
Dann hätte es jemand anders machen müssen, also die Stellungnahme wäre kürzer geworden. Kürzer geworden ist zum Beispiel die Stellungnahme in der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten.
Die hat eine Stellungnahme von elf Seiten eingereicht. Jetzt muss man natürlich auch sagen.
Die Qualität einer Stellungnahme ist nicht unbedingt in ihrer Länge bemessen, ne? Und das, wie ist dieses Zitat von Marc Train ähm.
Ich hatte keine, ich hatte wenig Zeit äh verzeihen sie daher, dass ich mich nicht kurz fassen konnte,
ne? Also ein Text ähm ein Text kurz und prägnant zu schreiben braucht mehr Zeit als Sachen runterzuschreiben? Klar.
Insofern ist nicht unbedingt ähm äh Quantität unbedingt Qualität. Aber ich glaube, diese Stellungnahme ist schon ganz ordentlich. So, da war ich auf jeden Fall mit zufrieden.
Der Bundesbeauftragten, der Datenschutzbeauftragten.
Unsere meine und ähm die von Andrea Voßhof habe ich nicht vollständig gelesen, weil ich äh schon ähm,
beim beim Lesen des Deckblattes äh sofort Kofe. Weil ähm die hat.
Also das muss man sich wirklich, das ist ähm nur mal um also darüber wollen wir heute so ein bisschen sprechen. Was da passt, also das Deckblatt, der.
Der Bundesbeauftragten für Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheit bei der Einreichung ihrer Stellungnahme zu dem zu der Formulierungshilfe des Änderungsantrages zum Staatstrianer, über die wir in der letzten oder vorletzten Sendung gesprochen hatten, was Andre geliegt hatte,
Sagt also.
Sehr geehrte Vorsitzende, den Frau damit meint, in dem Fall meint sie damit die Frau Künast, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, Abgeordnete. Beiliegen übersende ich ihnen meine Stellungnahme zu dem oben genannten Gesetzesentwurf.
Leider hat es das BM JV Bundesministerium für Justiz und Verbraucherschutz unterlassen,
Mich zudem mit der Formulierungshilfe eingereichten Änderungsantrag zur Einführung einer Quellentelekommunikationsüberwachung
und einer Online-Online-Durchsuchung in der Strafprozessordnung zu beteiligen.
Von dem Vorhaben habe ich erst am siebzehnten Mai,
zweitausendsiebzehn durch Medienberichte erfahren. Angesichts der erheblichen datenschutzrechtlichen und verfassungsrechtlichen Bedeutungen des Vorhabens ist für mich diese Verfahrensweise nicht nachvollziehbar,
Wegen der kurzen Zeitspanne, die mir für die Prüfung zur Verfügung stand, muss ich mich leider auf einige wenige Eckpunkte beschränken. Vielen Dank ähm,
Im Auftrag Andrea Voßhof oder sowas. So, das war wir reden hier übrigens, haben wir ja auch noch nicht gesagt von dem von der Formulierungshilfe für einen Änderungsantrag. Das ist schön. Also Formulierungshilfe ist, man muss sich das so vorstellen.
Die Bundesregierung hilft.
Der der Regierungskoalition den Abgeordneten im Bundestag dabei einen Änderungsantrag zu formulieren für das Gesetz, was sie gerade debattieren.
Ja, also die Regierung hilft, ne, die Exekutive äh hilft der Legislative doch hier.
Für freundlich auch.
Ja, ich hörte das eigentlich demnächst auch mal machen, dass ich denen mal ein paar Formulierungshilfen schicke.
Machen wir eigentlich auch Laufen hier.
Ich habe ja auch Formulierungshilfen schon. Na ja, also,
So und das diese es geht dabei, dieser Änderungsantrag ist einfach nur, wir möchten in der Strafprozessordnung,
Also, ne, normales Strafverfahren ähm geregelt haben, dass Strafverfolgungsbehörden ähm die Quellen TKÜ und die Online-Durchsuchung zur Verfügung steht.
QuellentKÜ, ist also, ne, wird gesagt, wir
wenn wir können die Telefone abhören, wir können das Internet abhören, aber wenn da verschlüsselte Verbindungen sind, dann dann haben wir nur verschlüsselten Salat. Also möchten wir die Endpunkte
mit einer Schadsoftware infizieren, äh damit wir diese Inhalte einsehen können, ja? Und die Argumente, die dann auch so von den.
Von den Staatsanwälten und.
BKA im Ausschuss vorgetragen wird, sind, sind entsprechend, ne? Ähm das Going Dark wurde da auch sehr sehr oft bemüht. Das ist diese äh ähm sehr viel zitierte Äußerung von James Comey, dem ehemaligen
FBI äh Direktor, äh der sich also seit der also sagte, ja, dadurch, dass die jetzt alle verschlüsseln, verschwinden die von unserer Bildfläche,
ja? Und deswegen müssen wir die hacken, damit wir ähm damit wir wieder die Kommunikationsinhalte sehen. Ähm,
Und dazu war ich eben gestern im Rechtsausschuss vor dieser Änderungsantrag, wo man das einführen wollte in die Strafprozessordnung äh eingeladen. Ist Strafprozessordnung,
Wie gesagt, Standardkriminalität geregelt. Die Online-Durchsuchung und die Quellen TKÜ als rechtliches oder als als Ermittlungsmethode. Gibt es in Deutschland seit zweitausendacht,
Ähm, da sei an die äh letzte Folge glaube ich erinnert, wo Konstanze kurz hier zu Gast war. Nee, es war die also die Vorletzte mit ihr als Gast
wo sie nämlich als Sachverständiger am Bundesverfassungsgericht in Karlsruhe war ähm zu der Beurteilung
des BKA-Gesetzes, das BKA-Gesetz wurde zweitausendacht erlassen. Dann wurde es irgendwie, gab's ja sofort äh Unmengen an an Widerspruchsverfahren dagegen.
Und ähm eines davon landete im in oder das Entscheidende landete in Karlsruhe und wurde viele viele ähm Jahre später ähm,
dort abgeurteilt. Ähm ich muss das, ich habe das in meiner Stellungnahme auch nochmal zusammengefasst. Ähm das war glaube ich zweitausendfünfzehn oder sowas.
Logbuch Netzpolitik hundertneunundsiebzig Flensburg für Verfassungssünder.
Genau, Datekonstanze dann nochmal ganz ausführlich drüber gesprochen.
Und ähm genau, seit zweite, seit zweitausendacht. Bis dahin galt ja das alte BKA-Gesetz, ne? Wir hatten also zweitausendacht äh Februar zweitausendacht äh wurde das ähm.
Wurde das Urteil gefällt zur Online-Durchsuchung, ja? Äh wo dann die Idee der ähm,
des Grundrechts auf gewährleisten der Vertraulichkeit und Integrität Informationstechnischer Systeme geboren wurde. Zweitausendacht. Ich glaube damals ähm Vertreter des Chaos-Computerclubs war Andreas Burg.
Wenn ich das Recht entsinne.
Mhm. Kann gut sein, ja.
Zweitausendacht, ja? Also dann im gleichen Jahr, am äh vierten Quartal wurde dann das BKA-Gesetz novelliert und.
Und damit wurden Quellen TKÜ und Online-Besuchungen eingeführt. Also jetzt könnte man sagen, seit zweitausendneun haben die das, ne? Und dann wurde da eben lange drauf rum debattiert
und Februar zweitausendsechzehn hatte das Bundesverfassungsgericht,
Nee, Quatsch, April zweitausendsechzehn hatte das Bundesverfassungsgericht dann endlich ein Urteil über dieses zweitausendacht, beziehungsweise zweitausendneun erlassene BKA-Novellengesetz. Ähm zweitausendelf.
Wiederum hatte der Chaos-Computerclub dann einen ähm Staatstrojaner des LKA Bayern ähm analysiert. Das ist das, was als Ozapft ist, äh glaube ich sehr äh sehr bekannt ist als äh,
Als wahrscheinlich größte Reichweite oder einflussreichste und krasseste Aktion des CDC in weiß ich nicht wie viel Jahren.
Um umfangreichstester äh Source-Code-Abdruck.
Medien auf jeden Fall.
Der also es war ein sehr sehr umfangreicher und sehr einflussreiche Veröffentlichung Veröffentlichung des Cars Computerclubs. Eine der vielen, aber das sicherlich eine der,
beeindruckendsten.
Ähm da war dann entsprechend, am wurden, mussten da bestimmte Staatsräder eingedampft werden, da gab's dieses Unternehmen digital, Ske, die äh die sich da echt mit diesem mit dieser
zum Horst gemacht haben und lange lange lange Debatten über die ähm nicht Rechtmäßigkeit dieses Vorgehens.
Februar zweitausendsechzehn im äh Abschluss der Prüfung. Nee, Entschuldigung, Februar zweitausendsechzehn hat erstmal noch das BKA ähm gesagt. Eier, wir haben jetzt einen Staatstruiner und der ist äh der ist in Ordnung,
Ja? Das war aber vor,
dem Abschluss der Prüfung durch das Bundesverfassungsgericht. Also so gehen die ja die ganze Zeit vor, ne? Als wir das BKA hat nicht
noch hat nicht abgewartet bis das Urteil gesprochen ist in Karlsruhe, sondern konnte schon vorher bekannt geben, dass sie jetzt etwas haben,
dem Gesetz und den Vorgaben und der Verfassung entspricht ja auch sehr interessant, woher sie das mit so großer Sicherheit sagen konnten.
Die haben da irgendwie so ein, so eine Glaskugel.
Na, es gibt diesen Prüfkatalog, äh der geheim ist, aber Andre hat den, glaube ich, schon mal bei Netzwerk Org veröffentlicht oder sowas,
Wie dem auch sei, wir reden aber bei diesem gesamten BKA-Gesetz. Immer noch nur von ähm Gefahrenabwehr und innerer Sicherheit, also Terror.
Online Durchsuchung und Quellen TKÜ zur zur Verfolgung zur Verhinderung von Angriffen, ne? Und zum zum,
bei schweren Straftaten und Terrorismus. Dieser.
Der in die Hände des CC gelangt ist, äh, wurde gegen jemanden eingesetzt, der wenn ich das Recht entsinne äh des Anabolika-Schmuggels bezichtigt wurde,
Wenn ich das also wie gesagt das auch schon wieder Ewigkeiten her,
ne? Aber das war also, ne? Da kann man das auch das ist sicherlich strafbar, ne? Aber es gibt eben einen Unterschied der Gefährdung der Allgemeinheit durch einen
Anabolika Schmuggler und durch einen Terroristen. Na wir sehen da irgendwo verläuft da eine eine Linie des Unterschiedes. Und ähm das ist eben der Unterschied, ob man jetzt BKA zu Gefahrenabwehr diese Mittel an die Hand gibt oder ähm,
der allgemeinen Strafverfolgung, also allen ähm,
Und im Fall der Quellen TKÜ sogar für alles, ne. QuellenTKÜ ist also im Prinzip geregelt bei welchen bei welcher,
Kriminalität du ähm Telefonabhören machen darfst, ne? Das ist irgendwie gibt's keine nennenswerten Einschränkungen. Bei der Online-Durchsuchung gibt es jetzt in diesem vorliegenden Gesetzesentwurf dann auch. Also da beschränken sie sich dann auf die strenge.
Oder auf auf schwerere Kriminalitätsformen. Auch da ein sehr langer Katalog, ne? Vierunddreißig sind das, glaube ich, Straftaten, Straftatbestände, die sie da benennen. Ähm.
Die Online-Durchsuchung bedeutet, du machst eine Volltreanisierung des Gerätes mit, du kannst eine Datei in dir anschauen, du kannst Mikrofon anmachen, einmal äh ähm.
Fernverwaltung.
Fernverwaltung, einmal einen Meter Breta, ne? Also dieser Standard äh Standard Trojaner von äh von Metasployd oder sowas, ne? Einmal einmal Meter Preter, gib ihm und ähm
kannst du einmal alles machen.
Ist das ein besonders bekanntes Tool? Ich kriege das gar nicht. Mieter, Brita.
MetaSployd ist so eine ähm ja und Meter Preter ist so die Standardplaylote Commanden Control Dings, die du dann irgendwie, wenn du mal,
wenn wenn du von einem, wenn du Lifehacking machen musst,
dann machst du einen Meter Fräter, glaube ich. Da sehe ich das immer, gibt ja diese Unternehmen, die äh die sich dann herauflassen, sowas zu machen. Ich musste es auch mal schon mal machen, um irgendwie, weil dann die Leute gesagt haben, zeig mal Trojaner. Ja, dann musst du halt Trojaner zeigen,
nimmst halt Meter brita.
Oder ozapft ist. Da haben wir ja auch eine Command-Kontroll-Software für. Ähm okay, ähm einmal alles, ne? Und die online äh die Quellen TKÜ wäre also ja wir.
Versuchen unseren Trojanereinsatz darauf zu beschränken,
deine, die für uns von Interesse seienden Telekommunikationsinhalte zu bekommen. Ähm also E-Mails zu erfassen, bevor sie gelesen sind,
Ähm.
Was weiß ich, Signal, Streamer, Telegramm, was nicht alles da gestern genannt wurde, an verschlüsselten Messengern, ähm quasi die Nachricht an die an den Nachrichten, den Unverschlüsselter Form zu gelangen, weil wir sie auf dem Transportweg nicht abhören können.
Und ähm das ist also.
Schwer möglich, ja? Und dass das so schwer möglich ist, war auch der Kernpunkt des der Veröffentlichung zweitausendelf des Chaoscomputerclubs, ähm wo nämlich gesagt wurde, na ja, also wenn man jetzt einfach nur mal sagt, äh wir sehen, die Person benutzt die Zielperson benutzt,
PGP zum Schreiben ihrer E-Mails, ne.
Und jetzt möchten wir eine ähm eine einen Staatstrojaner bauen, der PGP-Mails.
Abgreift und zwar Eingehende, ja? Und Ausgehende,
Ähm dann könnte ich jetzt natürlich sagen, okay, ich versuche dem eine.
Kaputte Variante oder eine eine manipulierte Variante des äh Open PGP Binaries zu geben, was einfach jedes Mal den Plantext nochmal dampft und mir gibt.
Ne, also jedes Mal, wenn Open PGP, Endgrip oder Decript, aufgerufen wird,
Mehrmodi gibt dieses Bein über den Plantext aus und schickt den irgendwie heimlich irgendwohin. Das wäre jetzt so, dann hättest du quasi eine PGP-Backdorf geschaffen, ja?
Also für Leute, die jetzt vielleicht auch über äh schon komplett aussteigen, so in dem Moment, wo jemand E-Mail-Verschlüsselung benutzt und im Prinzip äh das Verschlüsselte auf dem Weg ja nicht mehr abgefangen werden kann, ist man halt auf der Maschine und klingt sich genau
an der Stelle ein, wo dieser Verschlüsselungsvorgang stattfindet und greift einfach das unverschlüsselte im richtigen Moment ab.
So die so die Theorie, aber auch natürlich richtig schwierig. Und ähm das wäre jetzt ein Beispiel für einen Verein dieser Anwendungsfälle,
wo ich jetzt den äh im Zweifelsfall mich nachher mich noch ärgern werde, dass ich denen einen Tipp gegeben habe. Ähm aber
wie sie's am Ende gemacht haben, weil weil sie gesagt haben, oh Mann, ey, wir wissen nicht, welches PGP die benutzen. Wir äh die außerdem benutzen die vielleicht noch irgendwie ein äh äh OTR über
über Jabba, äh vielleicht nutzen sie auch noch irgendwie was weiß ich, WhatsApp oder so, das gab's damals noch nicht, ne? Aber es gibt also eine Vielzahl an verschiedenen Möglichkeiten, wie du ja dann verschlüsselt kommunizieren kannst und du kannst
kaum jeder einzelne davon erfassen, deswegen hat dieser äh dieser Ortsaft Ist-Trojaner einfach die Funktion gehabt, ähm Screenshots zu machen. Der hat,
massenweise äh Screenshots gemacht und.
Einfach mal gucken, was da tatsächlich auf dem Bildschirm abgeht.
Genau und das, da kann man auch noch hier auf die Folge mit Ulf Burmayer nochmal äh verweisen. Der, mit dem habe ich auch mal hier eine Folge Lokbuchnetzpolitik gemacht, der nämlich ähm,
Erzählte, wie damals dieser äh wie damals dem, dem Anwalt der Verdacht kam, dem äh Straf,
Verteidigeranwalt, der nämlich dann irgendwie die Akte bekam mit diesen ganzen Screenshots und sagte so, ja, hm, also das ist ja, kommt mir irgendwie komisch vor, ne? Ich nehme mal das Laptop hier und gib das mal jemanden, der sich damit auskennt und das kann doch gar nicht, ne? Wenn ich mir hier,
Ü anschaue, dann ist doch wohl Screenshots machen, geht doch wahrscheinlich ein bisschen über die Spezifikation. Die juristische Spezifikation hinaus, ne? Und das wurde ja auch dann im weiteren Verlauf festgestellt
dass dieser Staatstrainer, der da eingesetzt wurde, nicht den rechtlichen Vorgaben entsprach und das ist auch
Ganz ehrlich, sehr schwer und ich halte es für am Ende nicht möglich,
einen Quellen-TKÜ-Trojaner zu bauen, der ausschließlich Quellen-TKÜ macht und nichts anderes. Und der Grund dafür wird sein, das haben die ähm anderen Sachverständigen in der Anhörung. Ich gleite jetzt mal so langsam über.
Selber ja die Gründerfirmen, die selber genannt, dass sie nämlich sagten, ja äh die benutzen ja hier ähm Telegram, Signal äh ähm Threema, WhatsApp, weiß der Geier, was die alles benutzen.
Und so ein Quellenticker-Ütrojaner müsste jetzt jeder einzelne dieser Applikationen,
kompromittieren, ne? Und das geht, geht auf so einem auf so einem Smartphone nicht so einfach.
Du hast ähm ich bin dann interessanterweise gebeten worden, das einmal von Anfang bis Ende zu erklären, wie man so ein äh wie man Trojaner anbringt. Ich hab's in dreizehn Minuten geschafft.
Im Rechtsausschuss jetzt. Wow.
Im Rechtsausschuss auf Bitten von auf Bitten von ähm Patrick Sensburg.
Ach. Ja. Warum ist denn der da überhaupt? Also ist der auch in dem Rechtsausschuss oder war der zu Gast so.
Ähm ich bin mir nicht sicher, ich ähm ob der äh festes Mitglied dort ist. Das müsste mal kurz googeln. Also ich war diese Legislaturperiode noch nicht im Rechtsausschuss.
Ja
Mitglied des Rechtsausschusses und Vorsitzender dessen Unterausschusses Europarech.
Also der ist ja, der hat ja auch irgendwo, der hat ja eine Professur für ähm.
Ja, der ist so.
Recht irgendwo, insofern kann, also dass er qualifiziert dafür ist, ist glaube ich ohne ohne Zweifel ähm ob der da jetzt das ständige erste Mitglied ist oder nicht, weiß ich, ne.
Sieht mehr noch normal Mitglied aus hier, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Vorsitzende wie gesagt Renate Künast. Ähm, ich hab das, ich muss dazu sagen.
Und auch noch stellvertretendes Mitglied im Innenausschuss, also der ist wirklich überall.
Ich kann mir also ich kenne die Mitglieder des die normale Besetzung des Innenausschusses nicht und ähm ich habe im Gespräch gesehen, dass da gestern mehrere eher so Vertreter saßen, also die nicht ständigen Mitglieder.
Innenausschusses. Also das ist ein Rechtsausschuss. Besserausschus.
Im Rechtsausschuss, ja? Also dass äh dass da gestern sage ich mal, du kannst sicher vertreten lassen, musst du einfach eine MDB hin, ne? Ähm.
Und das ist auch es eben gestern an mehreren Stellen wohl passiert. War jetzt nicht so besonders gut besucht und war wohl auch nicht die erste Garde.
Ist ja auch nicht so wichtig. Ist ja nicht so wichtig. Geht ja nur um die.
Ist ja nicht so wichtig, du machst ja nur, geht ja nur um die um das um die Vollüberwachung, ja.
Anlasslose Vollüberwachung. Genau. Mhm. Ähm.
So jetzt noch waren wir kurz beim Thema QuellentKÜ, warum geht das nicht? So, nehmen wir mal so ein normales Telefon, ne? Sagen wir mal hier so ein.
Smartphone oder so ein Android oder ein iPhone, ist eigentlich egal. Die Unterschiede sind jetzt an der Stelle nicht so gravierend. Du brauchst auf jeden Fall,
Also die, die diese Systeme sind so,
Die Architektur dieser Systeme sind so gestaltet, dass eine Applikation nicht in den Space einer anderen eingreifen kann. Also was die, was weiß ich, die Freemar-App hat, kann die Signal App nicht sehen.
Ähm sehr, sehr ordentlich gesandboxt und ähm bei bei äh Android wird das dann irgendwie auch durch jeweils spezifische Nutzer und so weiter und Rechtenkonzepte auf Betriebssystemebene nochmal umgesetzt
du kommst nicht aus der einen Applikation in die andere. Es sei denn.
Du hast erhöhte Privilegien, also du bist ähm bist rot auf dem Gerät, ne? Ähm bist irgendwie ähm.
Der Supermann.
Der Supermann. Und dann kannst du.
Viele Dinge umgehen. Insbesondere ist ja das Hauptproblem bei diesem Telefon, was was der die freien Software Leute immer haben, dass sie die ja ruten müssen, ne? Also bei bei Android heißt es Routen, das heißt, du.
Erhebst deine Nutzungsprivilegien,
von dem Kontext der Applikation, in dem du ja dann sehr streng gefangen bist und wo du ja auch diese ganzen rechte Sachen hast, ne? Darf diese Applikation auf das Mikrofon zugreifen oder nicht. Ja ähm.
Und da muss der einmal rauskommen, dann bist du, dann bist du quasi rot und dann kannst du machen, was du möchtest, dann kannst du auch in den kannst du dir jetzt auch die Daten anderer Applikationen anschauen und so weiter, ne, dann bist du einmal ähm mit höheren Privilegien, da kannst dich da kannst dich da,
umschauen. Ähm, zu dem Zeitpunkt hast du aber quasi schon eine.
Mindestens zwei Sicherheitsmaßnahmen des des äh Telefonsumgang, nämlich erstes, dass du dich überhaupt irgendwie darauf installiert hast.
Weil normalerweise haben die ja Codes, also Apple zumindest hat schönes und du kannst so 'ne Applikation eigentlich gar nicht. Das Ding, das ist Apple,
Telefon weigert sich die Applikation auszuführen, wenn sie nicht von Apple zur Ausführung auf diesem Gerät signiert wurde.
Eigentlich eine Funktion, die sie haben, oben raubkopien zu verhindern, ne, damit du jetzt nicht, wenn ich jetzt äh dein, dein dein deins,
iPhone da Route und nehmen die Skype-App, ja und kopieren die rüber auf mein iPhone, dann wird mein iPhone die nicht ausführen, weil die, weil die,
Zertifizierte Willensbekundung von Apple fehlt, dass dieses Telefon das ausführen soll,
also so so einfach haben die das Ganze Raufkopieproblem in den Griff bekommen. Hat aber den schönen Nebeneffekt, dass sie damit auch das Trojanisierungsproblem sehr gut in den Griff bekommen haben, weil ähm
ein Staatstrojaner, wenn du keine keine Jaybreak-Lücke hast, wird ein Staatstrojaner.
Der nicht von Apple signiert ist, auf keinem Telefon dieser Welt laufen.
Sei denn du Jaybrings das Telefon, schaltest dieses umgehst das Codesing und.
Genau genommen muss er ja nicht von Apple signiert sein, sondern er muss von etwas signiert sein, was von Apple signiert wurde, sprich ein Developer, der halt bei Apple anerkannt ist, kriegt ein entsprechendes Zertifikat,
und äh das kann einerseits äh widerrufen werden, andererseits sollte halt jetzt äh die Bundesregierung sagen, aber machen wir einfach unser eigenes Developer-Zertifikat hier irgendwie Trojaner Ink, äh so das wäre halt ein bisschen auffällig und wenn man das mit irgendwelchen Shady Cover äh Unternehmen macht, nicht, das
Problem gibt's natürlich auch äh dass man die jetzt nicht sozusagen immer so genau weiß, wer jetzt hier eigentlich wirklich als Developer auftritt,
ne? Weil es muss ja auch in gewisser Hinsicht durchlässig sein und kann jetzt nicht mit so einer kompletten Background-Checking äh Geschichte einhergehen. Ähm
Dann wär's aber dann zumindest ein mehr oder weniger eindeutig zuzuordnen oder würde zumindest klare Pfade äh zeigen.
Dann halt das Zertifikat revoten. Und dann würde dem Spuk eine Ende.
Genau und dann wäre das halt sofort auf allen Maschinen dicht, ne? Genau, der, der Killswitch sozusagen.
Aber um das äh ich entschuldige mich auch wirklich, dass das so ein bisschen konfusion mir einfach durch seit gestern. Ähm.
So ein bisschen weg von der Technik und gehen wir mal so ein bisschen konkret in diese Anhörung.
Noch ganz kurz, du müsstest jeder einzelne dieser Applikationen sehr, sehr spezifisch hacken, um das zu erreichen, was eine Quellen-TKÜ ist und was du in der Realität dann machst, ist natürlich einfach so eine Screenshot-Nummer, ja? Das heißt, du greifst mehr ab als
Das rechtliche Konzept der Quellenticker Übir erlaubt,
ja? In der Praxis. Theoretisch und das da war ja gestern nur Theoretiker. Klingt das natürlich nach einer Bombenidee? Technisch ist das nicht so einfach realisierbar,
Das ist der Kernpunkt. Ähm der Argumentation. Also aber der, der Argumentation, dass es keine Quellen-TKÜ nicht geben kann,
Du möchtest zum nächsten Thema?
Nicht zum nächsten Thema, aber das Ganze war ja jetzt im Prinzip nur der Vorlauf von worüber reden wir jetzt,
mal, ne? Also was, was ist sozusagen hier jetzt Steak? Ähm,
Um jetzt vielleicht nochmal klar zu sagen, dass wir nicht alle Leute komplett verwirren. Es gab die Einladung, kurzfristig, aber es gab sie, für die Anhörung im Rechtsausschuss, der sich eben jetzt mit dieser Frage, es hat irgendwie eine gute Idee oder nicht,
beschäftigt. Und du hast dann innerhalb kürzester Zeit eine Stellungnahme äh geschrieben, eine Unterstützung, bist da aufgelaufen, das war gestern,
Wie lange dauerte der ganze Spaß.
Zwei Stunden ziemlich genau.
Okay. Und dann marschiert man dahin.
Sagst du hallo.
Akkreditiert.
Genau, schönen guten Tag, Linus Neumann, dann steht da schon so ein Namensschild bereit.
Dann unterhältst du dich noch vielleicht kurz mit dem Mitarbeiter des Abgeordneten, der dich da eingeladen hat und dem Abgeordneten selber.
Werde ich jetzt konkret eingeladen.
Die Linksfraktion in dem Falle glaub also der Abgeordnete der dann da war war Jan Korte, der war aber auch nur Vertreter weil die Haupt die,
Personen ständige ähm Abgeordnete dort nicht da war.
Wegen irgendwas.
Wegen ist nicht, ne? Also die die sind alle gerade so viel kann man glaube ich sagen,
enorm beschäftigt, ne? Das war das, warum ich das Eingang so lange ausgeholt habe. So ein Jan Korte, der wird natürlich jetzt gerade gescheucht von rechts nach links. So, ist ja klar. Und die die Koalition,
holt jetzt eben gerade ein Gesetzesentwurf nach dem anderen raus, ne? Wir reden ja hier über Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz, wir reden irgendwie über dieses
über diesen Staatsrojaner Kram, die werfen dann noch irgendwie gerade mit den Zeitungsverlegern hat Heiko Maas sich ja auch noch angelegt. Dann geht's um irgendwelche Familiennachzugsregelungen in einen anderen Ausschüssen, ne,
den fliegt ja jetzt gerade richtig mal so, die haben jetzt gerade richtig was zu tun. Und dann.
Agiert ja offenbar die Regierungskoalition auch auf diese auf diese unfaire Weise, ne? Das sowas mal schnell aus dem Hut gehoben wird, ne? Ich meine ein vollumfänglicher, vollumfänglicher Einführung von Staatstrojanern in die Strafprozessordnung,
Das holen die raus im Änderungsantrag irgendwie vier Monate drei Monate vor der Wahl, vor Ende der Legislatur.
Ähm und und werfen das mal eben noch schnell einen Rechtsausschuss, ja? Ähm und und während sie an ganz anderen Stellen
die die Opposition ausscheuchen und wissen, dass der größere Teil der Leute, die sich mit Überwachung und so auseinandersetzen, der Experten selbstverständlich gerade damit beschäftigt sind, äh den NSA Abschlussbericht zu schreiben, ne?
Also das ist schon wirklich ähm du kannst natürlich mit solchen mit solchen Tricks regieren. Aber das macht halt keinen guten Eindruck.
Ne? Und wenn du der, wenn du der, wenn du die Datenschutzbeauftragte zu dem Thema nicht zu Rate ziehst, kannst du offenbar auch machen.
Aber den ist halt scheiße. Aber das ist ja scheiße.
Aber das ist halt Scheiße. Und dann weißt, dann weiß natürlich auch jeder, dass da was im Busch ist und dass du gerade die demokratischen Prozesse, die in diesem Land irgendwie ähm ja.
Tradition sind und zelebriert werden. Dass du die gerade möglichst wenig minimieren möchtest,
Weil du offenbar etwas einmogeln möchtest, was du nicht der breiten öffentlichen Debatte stellen möchtest, sondern alle Wege versuchst,
Diese breite Debatte nicht zu haben.
Und das irgendwie dunkel mal eben schnell durchzuschieben, was ja geht. Jedes Mal, also die können da machen, was sie wollen, ne? Ähm dass wir das überhaupt öffentlich debattieren, hat damit zu tun, dass wir von den Medien eine Kapazität haben, diesen Prozessen zu folgen.
Ne, dass wir und das passiert hauptsächlich deshalb, weil die Journalisten, äh, was weiß ich, einen Kontakt zu den Abgeordneten pflegen, weil die Abgeordnete natürlich ähm entsprechende Aufmerksamkeiten generieren wollen für, für Ihre Themen, für Ihr Handeln und wenn du die einfach mal kurz dedorst.
Fällt halt das ein oder andere mal eben hinten runter. Und das kannst du natürlich auch taktisch machen. Das ist hier wie jetzt geschehen.
Ja, gut, kommst du rein, sagst du, also hallo, dann eröffnet äh Frau Frau, die Vorsitzende, Frau Renate Klüners, die Sitzung und sagt so
keine Audioaufzeichnung
Wir veröffentlichen nachher ein Protokoll, gab auch kein Livestream oder sowas, ne. Da saßen dann irgendwie ein paar Abgeordnete, paar paar Sachverständige, ein paar Abgeordnete und dann konntest du halt vortragen. Die ähm Sachverständigen waren.
Ähm das muss ich mal ganz kurz mir raussuchen. Also es auf jeden Fall war dort der Ulf Burmeier,
der ja sicherlich also ist ja auch bekannt hier, der bei uns auch schon in der Sendung war, ähm der die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte gegründet hat und ähm.
Und als Strafrichter tätig ist und ähm der auch ähm glaube ich auch am Bundesverfassungsgericht war als äh als Sachverständiger zum BKA-Gesetz. Äh zusammen mit Konstanze damals.
Da oder so gearbeitet hat.
Ah ja, stimmt, der hat da auch, der hat da auch schon irgendwie im Rahmen seiner.
Konkrete Erfahrungen gesammelt.
So, jetzt hat er, jetzt höre ich mal ganz kurz, dann war dort ähm da hat sich nämlich das letzte neue noch schnell was geändert. Ähm.
Der Fürther Oberstaatsanwalt Alfred Huber.
Dann wurde verlesen der der Oberstaatsanwalt beim Bundesgerichtshof Michael Greven, der dessen Flug wurde aber gecancelt, deswegen war der nicht dort,
Äh das wurde verlesen vom Oberstaatsanwalt beim Bundesgerichtshof Matthias Kraus.
Und dann war da noch der Osnabrücker Strafrechtler ahnt Sinn und jemand vom BKA,
Peter Hänsler, Vizepräsident äh des Bundeskriminalamts und dann Ulf Burmeier und ich, das müssten jetzt insgesamt sieben Personen gewesen sein. Ulf Pomeier hat dann so über die Schwere des Eingriffs gesprochen, ne, was ich jetzt, also ne, das du kannst.
Also man muss sich ja mal vorstellen, was das für eine,
Für eine Alptraum eigentlich ist eine Trojanerinfektion. Vor allem wenn das jetzt nicht irgendwie so ein Rancing Wedding ist, sondern ein ein Spionagetrojaner, ne. Das ist wirklich, da schaut dir jemand bei allem, was du mit dem Computer tust über die Schulter, der ähm,
Kann deine Festplatte durchsuchen, also das ist ein die Eingriffsschwere ist sowas von krass, dass ich ja selber Alpträume habe, dass das irgendwann mal jemandem bei mir gelingt. Ja, das haben wir ja alle.
Ja, das ist dann so richtig das Leben der anderen, ne.
Das ist dann.
Richtig ekelhaft so, ne? Und äh die das natürlich ein massiver Grundrechtsangriff, der der in seiner Schwere natürlich auch weit über das hinausgeht, was man vielleicht mal zweitausendachtzig schon erahnen konnte,
Ja, zweitausendacht, äh da gab's irgendwie grade das iPhone, ne? Da da haben die Leute, da war die Rede von Computer,
Hacken. Ja, heute ist nicht die Rede davon, äh, Messenger auf Telefon zu hacken, ja? Snapchat ist den natürlich auch ein Dorn im Auge, ne? Mit den entsprechenden.
Ja und was nicht sonst noch alles so auf Smartphones äh rumliegt, ne, also auch die ganze Sensorik, die heute dazukommt, Gesundheitsdaten et cetera, also das ist äh ein Problem, ne?
Und das hat der Ulf da äh entsprechend dargestellt und dann hattest du eben diese, ne, diese Oberstaatsanwälte und den ähm und den ähm
BKA Vertreter. Ähm und das ist natürlich dann ganz interessant, weil die erzählen dir ja dann und das fand ich, das war,
göttlich. Die haben dann hauptsächlich dieses Going Dark angeführt und sagten ja, also dass das,
Einhundert A ist das glaube ich der Telekommunikationsparagraph läuft ins Leere, weil es nichts mehr gibt, was wir damit erfassen können,
Das war so deren These. Und sie sagen und wir wissen ja, dass das die, dass das die Beschuldigten oder die Leute gegen die wir ermitteln,
gezielt machen und das haben zwei Leute angeführt, der äh der Alfred Huber und der Herr äh Matthias Kraus, haben angeführt, dass sie quasi bei der TKÜ merken,
die Menschen sagen darüber lieber was weiß ich, Dollar, verschlüsselter Messenger, darüber reden wir nicht am Telefon. Und.
Also ein Skandal, ja, dass die Kriminellen äh jetzt einfach die Kooperation mit den Ermittlungsbehörden einstellen, ja.
Ich fand das sehr lustig und da habe ich auch drauf eingewiesen, Gobing Dog,
heißt ist damit sagt Comi die Kriminellen verschwinden von der Bildfläche, wir wissen nicht mehr wo sie sind, wir haben keine Daten mehr von ihnen, ja? Hier sagt aber hier geben die freimütig zu, wir wissen wer die Kriminellen sind.
Wir haben ja sogar schon so viel Wissen über die, dass wir eine TKÜ gekriegt haben,
konnten ja schon einen Richter davon überzeugen. Da fragst du dich, woher habt ihr denn diesen Anfangsverdacht, ne?
Und noch mehr. Wir wissen sogar so viel über deren Infrastruktur, dass wir quasi sogar ihre Computer ausfindig äh und gezielt über das Netz ansprechen können.
Ich meine, das ist ja mal wirklich eine eine also weiß ich nicht, ob ich über dich so viel weiß, dass ich das sozus.
Ne, also die, die wissen wirklich was. Und dann kommt natürlich noch der der Punkt und leider.
Konnte ich diesen Punkt im Ausschuss nicht mehr bringen, worüber ich wirklich sehr ähm auch sehr enttäuscht bin, weil der Jan Korte musste früher weg.
Wieso konntest du dann nicht mehr.
Es ist so, in diesem, in diesen Ausschüssen
Genau, jetzt saßen wir deiner hat jeder erstmal seine Eingangsstellungnahme verlesen, das war bei den äh bei den Oberstaatsanwälten und äh dem äh Strafrechtler Arndt Sinn. Das war immer das Gleiche, ne?
War, also er war immer ja, braucht man super. Äh hier gibt's im Detail vielleicht die ein oder andere Verbesserung, da können sie meiner Stellungnahme lesen, aber mach das, mach das, mach das, mach das, mach das. Ulf und ich, seid ihr wahnsinnig, das wird sein,
Ähm.
Dann geht das los, da hat also jeder so fünf Minuten für einen Eingangsstatement. Ähm und der Herr Kraus hatte dann auch noch das von der Greven vorgelesen. So, dann kommt ähm die Fragerunde. Und zwar dürfen dann ähm jede.
Partei, wenn ich das richtig sehe oder jede Fraktion, ja, jede Partei darf dann eine,
Darf dann zwei Fragen stellen, entweder zwei Fragen an eine Person oder eine Frage an zwei Personen. So sind die Gepflogenheiten,
Und üblicherweise stellst du dann ähm natürlich die Fragen, den Sachverständigen, die du selber bestellt hast,
ja? Das ist auch jetzt kein äh großes Geheimnis, das ist gängige Praxis, dass sich dann derjenige oder diejenigen, die dich bestellt haben, sagen, ey,
Welche Fragen stellen wir dir denn am besten? Welche Punkte möchtest du denn nochmal ausführen,
So, ne, ist ja klar, die ne, wäre ja blöd, wenn du noch irgendwie was hast so, wozu du viel sagen kannst und ich habe gesagt, na ja, ich möchte einmal gerne was zur inneren Sicherheit sagen. Ähm.
Dann möchte ich was dazu sagen, dass eine Quellen-TKÜ nicht funktionieren kann und dann wäre es mir sehr, wenn wir sehr daran gelegen, dieses Coing Dark mal äh hier auseinanderzunehmen.
Und was konntest du davon nicht bring.
Na ja, da mir in der ersten Fragerunde zwei Fragen gestellt werden konnten von Jan Korte, habe ich also diese ersten beiden Fragen bekommen,
in der zweiten Runde war der gute Mann nicht mehr vor Ort. Der musste woanders hin.
Und dann fragt dich keiner, dann darfst du auch nicht antworten so.
So. Interessanterweise hat mich dann aber hat mich dann aber in der ersten Fragerunde hier der Patrick Sensburg gefragt. Was äh interessant ist, also ich habe auch kurz überlegt, ob der.
Ob dir gerade, also was der sich da gerade bei erlaubt? Ja, ob der mich träumen will oder ob der mir eine Falle stellen will, ähm denn was der ähm was der.
Also er hat dann so festgestellt, der begann so mit den Worten, ja ich ich stelle erstmal fest, hier sind fünf Leute unsere fünf unserer Sachverständigen dafür und zwei dagegen,
Und dann gab's natürlich direkt Gepolter, weil äh das ist ja eine unzulässige,
Also ne, so eine numerische Abwägung ist ja Quatsch, weil die SPD und CDU können immer mehr Sachverständige bestellen, ja? Ähm und die die Opposition hat eben jetzt durchgekriegt, dass eben ähm die,
die Linken mich dahin geschickt haben und die Grünen den den Ulf Burmayer,
So und wenn die und die anderen können ja bestellen, wie sie wollen. Sie sind ja nun mal in der Mehrheit, wenn die sagen, wir wollen fünf Leute da hinsetzen, dann können entsprechend mal dann kurz.
Also auch die Anzahl der Sachverständigen richtet sich nach dem Ausschuss Pop.
Nicht unbedingt nicht nach dem Ausschlussproports glaube ich nicht unbedingt, weiß ich nicht genau. Ich mir fällt nur immer auf,
dass da also die die können dann irgendwie, du kannst glaube ich so viele bestellen wie du willst.
Aber dadurch, dass der, dass der im Ausschuss ja eine Mehrheit der Regierungskoalition ist,
können die halt auch sagen, nee den wollen wir nicht oder sowas. Aber da da müsste man gucken, wie das, wie das wie das gerechtlich genau ist. Aber es ist ganz klar, dass äh nur einer von Grünen, aber,
Nur einer von Linken und dann noch,
Fünf beziehungsweise sechs weitere geladen waren und du dich natürlich fragst, das war jetzt nicht jeder jeder von einer Partei. Also da weiß ich nicht genau, wie das ist,
kenne ich nicht, die die Regelung da. Wer wir freuen uns auf den auf den Hinweis in den Kommentaren, ähm wie das genau zustande kommt. Ähm,
Aber so oder so eine zahlmäßige Abwägung ist ja wie ich meine, das ist ja jetzt nicht hier, wir machen, wir laden uns mal ein paar Leute ein und dann machen wir Schnickschnack, Schnuck und gucken so fünf, fünf, fünf zu zwei, angenommen oder so, ne?
So Finger da, als Gaste, kurze Unruhe und dann sagte er so, aber deswegen möchte er jetzt mal hier den vehementesten Gegner hören und vor allem jemanden, der als einziger technisch Ahnung davon hat
und zwar den Linus Neumann,
hat er mich gefragt, ob ich denn mal erklären könnte, wie so eine TKÜ von vorne bis hinten abläuft. Und dann dachte ich erst so, okay, ich meine, war eine Frage, auf die ich nicht vorbereitet war, aber ähm ist natürlich auch eine, die ich problemlos beantworten kann.
Also habe ich den dann erklärt, wie das funktioniert, wie es gerade auch schon so ein bisschen versucht habe,
und ähm dann habe ich noch erklärt, wie das Kernproblem dieses ganzen Vorgehens ist ja nun mal,
dass sie Schwachstellen brauchen, um die Geräte zu infizieren. Da ne, die können lange darüber reden, wie rechtlich zulässig ihre Staatstrianer Software ist oder nicht. Wir werden das dann prüfen,
aber sie müssen einen Weg finden, dass diese auf dem Gerät anzubringen. Und dass diese.
Schadsoftware anzubringen ohne dass der Beschuldigte davon Kenntnis hat, ne? Also vor.
Vor vielen Jahren war das dann mal üblich, dass man ähm so ein Windows-Rechner über Direct Memory Excess, über Fireware ähm,
aufgemacht hat, also entsperrt hat und dann die Installation durchgeführt hat,
ja dann so konntest du, dafür brauchtest du physikalischen physischen Zugriff auf das Gerät, ja? Und dann konntest du ähm konntest du deine Installationen durchführen. Und dann hast du mal jemanden
gesagt, oh, wir müssen aber jetzt mal ganz kurz ihren Computer auf Bomben testen oder sowas, ne? Das kann's natürlich heute, macht das niemand mehr. Du brauchst also lokalen Zugriff, ne,
eine lokale Zugriffsschwachstelle ist in dem Fall uninteressant,
Du brauchst eine eine Remote Code Execution. Brauchst irgendein oder in irgendeinem auf irgendeinem Wege, ne? Du kannst natürlich jetzt irgendwie noch versuchen, mit Fishing oder sowas zu machen, sehen wir ja auch. Äh regelmäßig die Fälle, die uns dann aus dem.
Aus dem Nahen Osten berichtet werden, wo dann Diszidenten äh Fishing E-Mails bekommen, ihren letzte Mal, wo Claudio Gornieri was auseinander genommen hat, das kam ja auch irgendwie per SMS oder so, da laden wir hier die,
Lottogewinn runter oder so was. Aber letztendlich brauchst du eine Schwachstelle auf dem Zielsystem. Wenn du religabel,
arbeiten möchtest, vor allem im Rahmen der STPO. Wir reden ja jetzt hier nicht mehr von wenigen Fällen, sondern von vielen hundert oder tausenden, ne? T. TKÜ sind viele tausende Fälle pro Jahr.
Wie zum Beispiel, was wir jetzt hier gerade so schön hatten mit unserem, mit unserer Rancim Ware, die halt diesen, diese Remotexpepution ausge, wie heißt das Ding nochmal gleich äh.
Reward Code Execution oder?
Genau, Warnergri, ja, das war halt so eine Sicherheitslücke, wo man einfach gar nicht groß anklopfen muss, da geht man mehr oder weniger direkt rein und dann ist man da.
Ist rein und mach's, gib's ihm. Hättest dann noch so, ne? Bis läufst du auch sofort. In dem Fall läufst du sogar sofort mit erhöhten Privilegien, weil das ein Server war, äh.
Was bei Smartphones hochproblematisch ist, weil die einfach ganz andere Security Modelle äh anstreben, die sich bei den alten PC äh Systemen nicht so ohne Weiteres von heute auf morgen etablieren lassen,
Sind natürlich so normale PCs hochgradig gefährdet und dann ist das einfach eine absolut realistische äh ein absolut
realistisches Angriffsszenario, dass das dann auch getan wird, ne? Also wer jetzt so mit dem Entwicklungsrechner durch die Gegend läuft, äh
der tatsächlich Ziel von so einer Trojaneraktion werden soll, da ist dann die Wahrscheinlichkeit auch nicht gering, dass dann entsprechende Sicherheitslücken vorliegen, mit denen das auch problemlos machbar ist.
Beim Telefon würdest du eher wahrscheinlich, also du kriegst, die haben ja jetzt keine Services auf, ne, die wirst du, da wird es schwieriger, ein Telefon würdest du vermutlich über irgendeine Schwachstelle im Browser kriegen, wenn so einen Drive Ball nehmen
oder du würdest,
Ja doch, ein, also eigentlich auf dem Wege, ja oder in irgendeiner Applikation, wo du irgendein wo desto da irgendein Overflow findest oder so, aber das wird, das wird schwierig. Das wird auch teuer, diese Schwachstellen zu kaufen,
Aber diese Schwachstellen, die du brauchst, notwendigerweise, das haben wir ja lange jetzt zu Wollegri äh gesehen,
Die muss müssen ja auf allen Systemen der Welt vorhanden sein,
Weil wenn du auch nur irgendjemanden verrätst, wie diese Schwachstelle geht, dann wird die ja gefixt werden oder wie das Ausnutzen dieser Schwachstelle geht, ja? Mit anderen Worten, du musst es geheim halten, du musst gezielt in Kauf nehmen, dass die ähm.
Dass die Welt diesem Risiko dieser Schwachstelle ausgesetzt ist. Und zwar jeden Tag. Und damit gehst du auch natürlich das Risiko ein, dass jemand anderes diese Schwachstelle findet.
Spaßfakt, dieser gute Herr Henzel hat mir dann ernsthaft in dem Ausschussschuss vorgehalten, sagte wenn der Herr Neumann doch seit Jahren Sicherheitslücken sucht
findet und die berichtet, ne? Da möchte ich doch wenigstens mal darauf hinweisen, dass der in fünf Jahren es nicht geschafft hat, die One Agry-Lücke zu finden,
Also mit anderen Worten, ich bin daran Schuld, ne?
Und er hat noch weiter gemacht. Der Mann war sowieso, der war der war Zucker, ey. Der war wirklich Zucker. Der hat dann sagt er,
und und außerdem, was ich hier für einen Popanz, so ungefähr, also war jetzt nicht wörtlich, ne? Aber was ich jetzt hier für ein, für ein, für ein, für 'n Quatschrede von innerer Sicherheit,
nur weil man ein paar Krankenhäuser und die Deutsche Bahn betroffen waren, da könnte man ja auch mal drüber streiten, ob die Deutsche Bahn jetzt kritische Infrastruktur ist.
Kein Scheiß.
Oh Got.
Ich bin hinten übergefahren.
Nein. Also das was.
Also und deswegen war ich also ich ich hätte sehr, sehr gerne mal,
gegeben, ähm dass du mal fragst so was, also ob man von diesen Menschen sich Rat geben lassen möchte, ja, der, der offenbar einen Angriff auf ein Krankenhaus und und und auf die öffentliche Verkehrsinfrastruktur,
Oh.
Das ist wirklich nicht zu fassen, oder?
Alter. Ich habe, also ich mir, ich bin ich saß da, ne.
Was ist denn dann für die überhaupt noch kritische Infrastruktur, die CDU-Parteizentrale oder was.
Doch nichts heilig. Geil war, geil war auch, äh wenn wir jetzt mal hier so schon bei Money Codes sind, ne? Dieser Herr Huber, der war also der am geilsten war wirklich Huber und äh und Hansel, ne.
Der Herr Huber, von ihm stammte dieser Ausspruch dieser hundert A läuft ins Leere, ne? Wir haben den nicht mehr. Wir dürfen das,
Aber wir können es technisch nicht mehr erreichen, dann deswegen brauchen wir jetzt eine Quellen-TKW, ne? Dann guckst du dir an, TKÜ-Statistiken habe ich auch in meiner Stellenstellungnahme ähm zitiert. Das waren.
Einundzwanzigtausendneunhundert Anordnungen zur Überwachung von Mobilfunkkommunikation dreitausenddreihundertzweiunddreißig Anordnungen zur Überwachung von Festnetztelekommunikation siebentausendvierhundertzweiunddreißig Anordnungsüberwachung von Internetkommunikation. Zweitausen,
fünfzehn, ja? Und dann sagt er,
Ja, das, das Verfahren, das läuft ins Leere, wir wir kriegen das oder wir dürfen das nicht, ne? Äh äh wir wir dürfen das, aber wir kriegen die Daten nicht, weil die jetzt alle Going dark machen, ne? Er sagte. Und dann wird der gefragt, na ja,
heißt das denn, dass sie denn jetzt die Quellen-TKÜ auch massenhaft einsetzen wollen, beziehungsweise wurde er gar nicht gefragt? Das hatte der Ulf Burmeier schon gesagt
Der sagte so, Quäntika Ü ist hier Standardrepertoire, ne? Das ist nix, was sie irgendwie mit mit großer Vorhaltung machen. Das wird irgendwie richtig massiv eingesetzt so, ne? Und dann, dann setzt sich der Huber hin,
und sagt nein, also das kann ich ihnen, das werden wir ganz selten nur machen. Das werden wir nur ganz selten zum Einsatz bringen. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass wir da auf die Zahlen kommen. Und dann sagt er irgendwie, ja, wir haben nur zwanzig Prozent Aufklärungsquote bei Wohnungseinbrüchen, ne? Wenn,
Die Zahlenspiele, die dieser Mann da vorgetragen hat. Da hat jeder fünf Kläster gemerkt, dass der da, dass der halt mal hü mal Hot sagt, ne,
Einerseits die so das große Ding an die Wand malt, das große Risiko going dog, der hat sich sogar, also muss man auch sagen, ich.
Vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Respekt vor dieser Tätigkeit des Sachverständigen. Auch wenn man mir allgemein ein relativ respektloses Vorgehen ähm,
nachsagt, bin ich ja beachte ich ja äußerst genau darauf, dass das, was ich da sage, den Tatsachen entspricht. Der.
In so einer Situation macht jedermann Flüchtigkeitsfehler, ne? Aber dass ich mich hinstelle und zu der Vorsitzenden des Rechtsausschusses sage, wenn sie uns dieses Mittel nicht geben, dann tragen sie die politische Verantwortung an den nicht aufgeklärten Fällen.
Soweit wäre ich nicht gegangen,
Das hat nur der gute Herr Huber ein an dieser Stelle gemacht. Der hat wirklich der der Ausschussvorsitzenden Renate Künast mit der persönlichen Verantwortung für die nicht Aufklärung von Straftaten gedroht.
Wenn sie ihm dieses Ermittlungsmittel nicht gibt.
Ähm der Herr Kraus hat auch äh gesagt, ähm den habe ich nachher darauf angesprochen, habe ich gesagt, entschuldigen sie mal,
War schockiert, weil sie haben ja hier äh der in diesem Ausschuss offen mit Rechtsrechtsbruch gedroht,
weil er sagte, wenn sie das jetzt hier nicht regeln, die Quellen-TKÜ mit diesem Änderungsantrag.
Dann wird die Quellen-TKÜ auf Basis von einhundert A gemacht. Mit anderen Worten, ne, Telekommunikationsüberwachungsparagraf wird genutzt,
Und wir wir hacken dann einfach so die Geräte, ja? Ohne,
ohne die paar Vorgaben, die es ja immerhin in diesem Erinnerungsantrag gibt, nämlich wie eine Quellen-TKÜ zu sein hat und wie nicht und dass man sie immer zum Einsatz bringen darf. Ähm und da habe ich ihnen dann sagte er, nein, das hätte er nicht.
Damals Unrecht war, muss es heute recht sein, ja?
Er meinte aber damit nicht, dass er es persönlich tun würde, der gute Mann war eh irgendwie in der Gefahrenabwehr Terroristenjagd und so zu
zuständig, der Thais-Devel beschäftigt sich eh den ganzen Tag mit was anderem. Ähm, und macht das auch schon, ne? Sie bringt diese Mittel zum Einsatz, sondern er sagte, naja, er kennt ja die anderen, er kennt ja die, die anderen Staatsanwälte in anderen Bundesländern,
die entsprechend ja wie wir es eben auch zweitausendelf in Bayern gesehen haben ohne rechtliche Grundlage diese Mittel einsetzen.
Ja, also das äh,
äh den habe ich da äh sehr also die Äußerung habe ich übel wahrgenommen, weil er sagte, dann machen wir es ohne Rechtsgrundlage, aber er meinte eben, er hat jetzt nicht in der ersten Person Plural oder Singular gesagt, sondern in Seite sonst kommt es,
so oder so zum Einsatz, ne? Das kann man sich jetzt auch äh.
Fragen, wie gut das ist oder nicht. Ähm hatte ich sonst noch Money Codes? Ich habe leider meinen Zettel nicht mit. Ich hatte noch so ein paar Money-Kurs von den Jungs.
Na dann sagt er jetzt doch mal was zu deine deine deine Linie war jetzt eigentlich in in der Stellungnahme.
Also die Linie war äh die Stellungnahme trägt den Titel äh Risiken für die innere Sicherheit beim Einsatz von Schadsoftware in der Straßverfolgung und die regelmäßigen äh zuhörenden von Logbuch Netzpolitik,
haben vielleicht eine Idee, äh wer die von wem die Idee mit der inneren Sicherheit ursprünglich kam oder die Inspiration, das war hier unser Timmer.
Der vor ein paar Folgen ja gesagt hat so, wird eigentlich mal Zeit, dass die innere Sicherheit mal wieder ernst nehmen und das ist halt richtig, ja? Und ähm.
Es ist auch so, dass die SPD ja gerade dafür vor sich hergetrieben wird, dass sie kein Konzept für die innere Sicherheit hätte, ne. Ähm und äh mit diese, ich glaube, dass das auch der der,
Der Special Haare ist, an der die SPD gerade in diese Nummer reinziehen, ja? Dass sie sagen, hier innere sicher, ihr wollt wollt ihr.
Ja, wenn ihr nicht mitmacht und so weiter, stellen wir euch wieder an den Pranger.
So, ne, dann dann sorgen wir das bald dafür, dass bei der Pressekonferenz ein Scania LKW im Hintergrund steht, wenn ihr wenn ihr den Staatstrojaner nicht äh nicht mit einführt, ne? Also,
Einmal die Argumentationsgefahr für die innere Sicherheit war durch äh,
Sicherheitslücken und da habe ich, kann man auch mal drauf hinweisen, ne? Äh dieses Datum, wann der dieser, diese Formulierungshilfe kam, ist der fünfzehnte Mai.
Das ist ein Montag gewesen. Und das ist ein Montag gewesen nach dem zwölften Mai. Drei Tage vorher haben diese One Acryl Sachen eingekracht,
Es war also du hast Freitagabend am zwölften gegen die anders äh in Großbritannien mit einer NSA-Sicherheitslücke gerade äh die,
Ja, kritische Infrastrukturen, wie wir gelernt haben, ist ja ein großes Wort, aber halt ein paar Krankenhäuser ähm auf auf mit Stift und Papier wieder gearbeitet und haben und paar Operationen abgebrochen werden mussten, aber sonst ne, eigentlich ist ja nichts passiert.
Wir würden ja gerne ihr Leben retten, aber wir kriegen gerade unsere Kisten nicht gebutet.
Ja, also da genau Gefahr für die innere Sicherheit, dann natürlich und das ist der, das ist ja der Kernpunkt hier, deswegen war ich auch so überrascht, dass die nur Leute da hatten, die.
Mit den schwereren Verbrechen arbeiten, ja, die also schon denen diese Mittel auch schon zur Verfügung stehen. Ähm,
Denn wir wie gesagt, die haben's seit zweitausendacht, wir reden jetzt hier von Staatstrojaner für die Massen. Einsame habe ich äh einen Artikel, ein einen Absatz darüber geschrieben, das ist ein schwerwiegender unverhältnismäßiger Grundrechtseingriff ist, mit einer sehr,
niedrigen Schwelle.
In diesem Gesetz, ne? Online-Durchsuche lassen wir mal außen vor, äh Quellenticker ist hier die größere Gefahr, weil das eben für die komplette Breite ja zugelassen werden sollte.
Haben wir auch noch ein bisschen ausgeführt warum es eben du kannst nur eine Quellen TKÜ nicht wirklich bauen. Er wirst so wahnsinnig bei. Ähm dass er die am laufenden Bein irgendwie die die Apps updaten sich die du machst am Ende greifst du einfach auf das Mikrofon zu
fertig oder du greifst auf das auf den auf das Display zu oder du greifst auf die Tastatur zu, machst den Keylorgan, ne?
Dann äh fehlender Beleg der Notwendigkeit und das war eben, das wäre der Punkt, den ich so unglaublich gerne noch gebracht hätte, wo ich aber dann eben aufgrund der Abwesenheit von Jan Korte nicht mehr in der Fragerunde gefragt wurde. Ähm.
Der wird sicherlich einen guten Grund dafür gehabt haben, aber ich bin eben auch nur einmal da, ne,
Ähm denn wenn man sich jetzt mal anschaut, welche Methoden die noch alles zur Verfügung haben.
Internetüberwachung, Mobilfunküberwachung aus der Mobilfunküberwachung machen sie eine, machen sie mit den stillen SMS äh seit jeher eine eine digitale Observation, ne, wo sie die Leute verfolgen, wann in welchem Wort sind. Die machen Funkzellenabfragen.
Und sie haben jetzt auch, ne, ab ersten Juli oder wann äh oder erster Juni, ab heute, ich weiß es gar nicht genau, die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. So, das heißt, es gibt eigentlich nichts mehr.
Was wir an Daten irgendwo hinterlassen worauf die keinen Zugriff haben. Es gibt nichts mehr. So, ja, wir haben alles.
Das einzige was sie nicht haben sind die paar verschlüsselten Messages, die du am Tag schickst.
Auf alles andere haben sie Zugriff.
Schildern das aber natürlich hier in einer äh in einer in einer Situation, in der diese VDS halt noch nicht durch ist. Also sie konnten ja quasi die konnten sich ja ehrlich dahinstellen und und so tun, als gäb's keine VDS.
Bei gibt's ja erst morgen. Bald gibt's erst morgen.
Weil gibt's erst morgen so, ne? Erzählen sie mal aus ihrem Alltag. Ja, gibt keine VDS in meinem Alltag, ja. Ähm,
Und diese diese Metapher des Going Dark ist also wirklich eine.
Eine pöswillige Lüge und ich hätte sehr gerne mal die darauf hingewiesen, dass zu keinem Zeitpunkt Strafverfolger mehr Daten.
Bequemer zur Verfügung standen. Wenn ich wirklich einen auf Going Dark machen würde, dann würde ich einfach mein Telefon ausschalten und keine Computer benutzen.
Ja? Und dann werden wir irgendwie zurück in den Achtzigern oder sowas, ne? Und jetzt also Festnetztelefone jetzt mal außen vor gelassen, ne?
Das wäre going dog. Und das ist diese Metapher, die sie da haben. Aber äh oder die Comida gebracht hat,
Die Tatsache ist doch, dass sie eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben über allen Scheiß, dass sie bei den E-Mail-Providern reinreiten können, dass sie überall mit ihren Anordnungen reingehen können, außer irgendwie besonders krasse Dienste im Ausland.
Ist ein Punkt, muss man sich mal Gedanken drüber machen, aber dafür mal eben zu sagen, jetzt, jetzt wollen wir bei jeder Art von von Strafverfolgung ähm jede Art von informationstechnischen Gerät hacken können, ne? Da kommt ja dann demnächst noch ähm.
Er kommt ja dann demnächst noch äh hier äh IOT Zinhober dazu, ne? Wer sagt denn, dass die nicht, wenn die mein Telefon hängen? Wer sagt ja nicht, dass sie meine meine Uhr hacken.
Ne? Mit äh mit Pulsmessgerät und was nicht alles dran, ne? Ist ja auch ein Kommunikationsgerät.
Sie haben schon einen Exploid für die Apple Watch.
Ach was weiß ich. Jetzt hast du ja verraten, dass ich ein Apple Watch habe, Alter. Peinlich. Das das schneiden wir raus. Das schneiden wir raus. Ich kann das erklären.
Ich kann das erklären.
Arsch.
So, ne, also die haben Unmengen an Daten und müssten jetzt einfach mal, also der Beleg der Notwendigkeit ist nicht da, ja? Und das beste Argument für die Notwendigkeit, was diese,
Experten der Uni Sono vorgetragen haben ist, dass sie bei einer TKÜ hören, dass die Leute bestimmte Dinge verschlüsselt.
Behandeln wollen. Und da habe ich ihnen gesagt, also ne, das Entschuldigung, das kann doch nicht sein so, ne, dann dann habt ihr doch schon längst einen Anfangsverdacht, dann können wir doch, reden wir doch nicht von Gobing Dark
so, wovon wollen wir denn dann? So, dann aber dann sagte mir der Herr äh Kraus nachher, wirklich, der war auch ein netter Typ ähm im im Gespräch danach. Ähm,
sagte dann ja, das ist also so, was sie mit dieser TK Ü in Erfahrung bringen.
Im Rahmen der Gefahrenabwehr. Das dürfen sie nachher nicht als Beweis vor Gericht verwenden.
Jetzt frage ich mich, na ja okay, wann ähm.
Und wollte dann damit.
Was wollt ihr denn damit? Nee, äh gibt's irgendwie einen Unterschied zu Gefahrenabwehr und dann sagte
Sagte der Olf, ich bin ja nicht der Jurist, ne? Ulf sagte dann, ja, das stimmt, ist ein Problem, da muss man aber dieses Problem lösen, ne
dass sie ähm dass sie, dass man quasi, also ich habe ihnen gesagt, wenn sie doch wissen, die verschlüsseln, ja? Und auf welche Weise, dann holt euch doch eine Hausdurchsuchung, marschiert rein, holt den Computer da raus.
Oder sowas, ne? Ja, das geht eben so einfach nicht, weil das äh quasi der Beleg, dass sie jetzt einen Computer beschlagnahmen müssen, den können sie,
Den Beweis dafür oder Beleg dafür können sie nicht aus dieser TKÜ-Maßnahme erbringen,
Ich kann nur wiedergeben, was mir da erklärt wurde und wenn das der Kraus sagt und der Olf Burmeier bestätigt, dann und es dann nicht stimmt, dann habe ich's jetzt gerade falsch wiedergegeben. Aber da gab's ein Problem. Das kann man aber natürlich an anderer Stelle lösen. Da muss man jetzt nicht die Geräte für hacken.
Und dann haben wir noch ein relativ weit äh äh ein Teil darüber geschrieben,
Also fehlender Beleg der Notwendigkeit, weil der dritte Teil deine vierte fehlende technische Überprüfbarkeit und Nachvollziehbarkeit. Wir haben also relativ wenig dazu geschrieben,
Wie machst du denn sowas rechtssicher, ne? Es steht dann drin, ja, wenn irgendwie der Kernbereich berührt wird, müssen die Daten gelöscht werden, ne?
Und da haben wir habe ich ein, einfach mal größtenteils zitiert aus den italienischen Vorgaben, die wir hier auch vor einigen Wochen oder Monaten schon mal diskutiert hatten.
Wo sie gesagt haben, na ja okay, wenn wir diesen Staatstrojanerkampf jetzt verlieren, ne, dann äh machen wir wenigstens die entsprechenden Anforderungen,
An den Quellcode, dass der hinterlegt ist, unverifizierbar sein muss, einsehbar sein muss, prüfbar sein muss, ne? Ähm jede Aktion,
Muss vollständig Manipulationssicher und verifizierbar dokumentiert werden, ja? Dass du also quasi sowas hast wie ein Log,
In dem drin steht, dann wurde Datei mit Prüfsumme X geholt. Dann wurde
Am Mittwoch um neunzehn Uhr das Mikrofon eingeschaltet und am Donnerstag um zwanzig Uhr wieder aus, ne? Jede, jede Aktion oder auch es wurden Dateien mit folgenden Prüfsummen geholt,
Äh die wurden aber als Kernbereichsrelevant äh festgestellt und wieder gelöscht. Ne, sowas wird's ja, also sowas witzt ja alles
in einem sicheren Lock haben, sicheres Loging ist gar nicht so einfach, ne? Ich würde halt, ich würde es im Prinzip mit einer, mit einer, mit einer Hashtaine machen, ne, hast aber immer noch das Problem, dass du irgendwie sicherstellen musst, dass der
dass alle Sachen auch wirklich gelockt werden, aber dass jetzt äh eh nochmal irgendwie ein Ex-Kurs in in die Informatik.
Dann eine sehr wichtige Anforderung, ähm die Schadsoftware darf nicht das allgemeine Sicherheitsniveau des Geräteschwächen,
Und das war ja zum Beispiel bei dem ähm bei dem Ozapft ist der Fall, ne? Da konnte die konnte Code nachgeladen werden. Das Gerät war nach der Infektion.
Insgesamt unsicher reher als vor der Infektion.
Und das ist auch wichtig bei hier bei den bei den Smartphones, ne? Wenn die, wenn ihr irgendeinen Trojaner drauf aufbringen wollen und das und den dafür das Gerät dafür Jaybraken müssen,
Was sie ohnehin müssen, weil du willst ja aus dem Kontext deine Applikation raus in andere,
dann hast du dieses Gerät in seinem, in seinen Verteidigungsmöglichkeiten gegen weitere Angriffe geschwächt. Und das darf, darf nicht sein.
Dann äh die Entwicklung und der Einsatz der Schadsoftware muss mittels einer zentralen Erfassung nachvollziehbar sein mit anderen Worten, ne, das mit den Loks muss natürlich auch für die komplette, für den kompletten Trojaner und Trojaner Einsatz gelten.
Und eine Unabhängig Z unabhängige Zertifizierung muss die technischen und datenschutzrechtlichen Vorgaben,
regelmäßig prüfen und die Zertifizierung muss erneuert werden. Das ist etwas, was die was sie ja auch machen, das sagen die ja sogar, ne? Da haben wir, ich glaube, das ist, ich weiß nicht, ob das immer noch CSC macht,
Aber das hatte ich damals schon irgendwie im zweitausenddreizehn in meinem Vortrag äh Bullshit Made in Germany das CSC, dieses Unternehmen, äh das irgendwie auch D-Mail mitelf geprüft hat, die prüfen wir heute, haben wir auch damals den Staatsreader geprüft, ne. Aber ist natürlich alles geheim,
dann machst du eine geheime Prüfung. Ist ja totaler Scheiß, ne? Das ist alles in Ordnung, das haben wir geheim geprüft, kann ich das mal sehen? Nein.
Ähm dann natürlich Verschlüsselung und Integritätsschutz für erfasste Daten, ne? Irgendwann muss ja auch irgendwie ich unterstelle ja gar nicht den den ähm Strafverfolgern, dass sie jetzt irgendwie sagen, guck mal hier dieses Foto von einem nackten Kind
haben wir von deinem Handy geholt mit unserem Staatstrianer. Aber wenn sie das bei jemandem behaupten, dann sollen sie doch müssen sie doch bitteschön äh das.
Fest, kryptografisch belegen können,
Ne, dass du sagst so, wir haben diese Datei geholt und es gibt diesen Blick und es war auch nur diese Datei und keine andere. Und äh die ist liegt hier verschlüsselt vor. Ja und solche Sachen.
Die Beweisbarkeit des Beweises.
Genau und da haben wir halt also gesagt, ne, so ne. Da habe ich auch zum Beispiel von ähm von anderen äh Gegnern von Staatstrainern, die haben natürlich auch gesagt, ey, so.
Muss das unbedingt sein, dass dir dass du diese Anforderung da definierst, weil wenn du Pech hast, übernehmen sie die, ne? Na ja, gibt's natürlich zwei Seiten dieser Medaille, wenn man sagt, ja, wenn ich Pech habe, übernehmen sie die, ja? Aber ähm,
Das Pech, dass das bald der Staatstrainer kommt, ist sowieso sehr wahrscheinlich und dann kann ich quasi das das drohende Pech äh in seinem, in seiner, in seinem äh fürchterlichen Ausmaß leicht mindern. Abgesehen davon habe ich gesagt, keine Sorge, die haben noch nie auf mich gehört.
Insofern mach dir keine Sorgen,
Ähm na ja, dann und der letzte Punkt ist eher ein vorsichtig theoretischer äh unter da haben wir einfach nur mal was angemerkt. Und zwar wollen ja in dem Paragraph hundert A sagen sie äh Konvent Hannel, TKÜ oder Quellen, TKÜ.
Sind jetzt das gleiche und dürfen. Ja und dann haben sie ähm weiter eine ähm Mitwirkungspflicht definiert.
Ähm und die gilt für Anbieter.
Und Telekommunikation, also für für Telekom für Telekommunikationsdienste. So und jetzt möchte die ähm,
Gleichzeitig hat der Bundesrat angeregt, dass weil ja jetzt alles über Messenger geht und der Begriff des Telekommunikationsanbieters nicht mehr,
so gilt,
Ne, also Telekommunikationsanbieter verkommen nach und nach zu den Leitungsbetreibern, ne? Äh und es gibt aber diese vielen anderen Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten, die wir gerne als Staat regulieren möchten.
Facebook, Messenger, all dieser ganze Kram.
Und in dem Moment, wo sie das machen, ähm ist das natürlich äh schlecht.
Weil dann würde das da gelten, nämlich der Absatz der Überwachung und Aufzeichnung der Telekommunikation darf auch in ein in der Weise erfolgen, dass mit technischen Mitteln in
Von den betroffenen genutzte informationstechnische Systeme eingegriffen wird, wenn dies notwendig ist, um die Überwachung und Aufzeichnung insbesondere in unverschlüsselter Form zu ermöglichen. Auf den informationstechnischen Systemen,
Betroffene gespeicherte Inhalte und Umstände, Kommunikationen dürfen überwacht und aufgezeichnet werden, wenn sie auch während des laufenden Überwachungsvorgangs im öffentlichen Telekommunikationsset in verschlüsselter Form hätten, Überwachung aufgezeichnet werden können. So und an weiterer Stelle sagen sie eben
dass ähm Telekommunikationsbetreiber und.
An der dieser Dienstleistung, an der Erbringung, dieser Dienstleistung beteiligte, eine Mitwirkungspflicht dabei haben,
und wende jetzt diesen Kreis der Telekommunikationsbetreiber aufbohrst, dann gilt auf einmal das und die Konsequenz wäre.
Dass du eine rechtliche Mitwirkungspflicht mit hier Strafzahlung und Beugerhaft und was nicht alles gegen Signal hättest. Wenn sie dir keine TKÜ ermöglichen. Und das wiederum,
ist, äh, wäre also eine Verpflichtung, der Dienstanbieter zur Duldung von staatlichen Hintertüren in ihren Diensten, die den
Eckpunkten deutscher Kryptopolitik widersprechen. Die Eckpunkte deutscher Kryptopolitik wurden mal
dem vom Innenministerium zweitausendneun neunzehnhundertneunundneunzig formuliert. Und gleichzeitig wurde aber mehrmals wiederholt gesagt, ähm.
Also hat sich das äh dass die die äh der Bundestag und so wieder zu denen bekannt und gesagt, ja, wir wollen Kryptografie nicht kaputt machen.
Wenn ihr einen Dienst anbietet, der verschlüsselt ist, dann machen wir euch den nicht kaputt.
Aber wenn jeder dich selber kaputt macht, dann machen wir euch.
Dann machen wir die Geräte kaputt über die darauf zugegriffen wird. Ist halt eine andere Sache. So kann man schon, muss man schon sagen und ich ich,
ich lebe auch lieber in einer Welt, in der die immer noch mein Gerät hacken müssen, als in einer Welt, wo äh Signal und WhatsApp und so verpflichtet sind. Äh das kaputtzumachen für mich, was, weshalb ich diesen Dienst nutze.
Das ist eigentlich das Schlimmste, was uns passieren kann.
Das ist das Schlimmste. Deswegen haben wir da nur vor, so noch gesagt, so ey, aufpassen, Jungs, so das kann schnell nach hinten losgehen.
So, das war die, das war die Stellungnahme und ich habe jetzt glaube ich auf.
Genug davon erzählt, wir müssen halt jetzt gucken, also der Bundesbundestag läuft auf Sparflamme, ne? Die SPD ist sehr in die enge gedrängt. Ähm.
Ich weiß nicht, ich kann mir, ich kann mit dieser Partei nichts mehr anfangen, ich verstehe nicht, was die tun.
Ich weiß nicht welche Strategie die verfolgen, welche Strategie die haben. Ähm,
Wenn die jetzt diese Staatstruana-Mist mitmachen, dann glaube ich, kann man ganz klar allen Beteiligten, sowohl der CDU, von der man aber nichts anderes erwartet, als auch der SPD, von der man aber nichts anderes erwartet. Ähm ganz klar sagen, dass das eine,
dass da fahrlässig ein Gesetz wohlwissend, dass es,
viel Widerstand und Probleme mit diesem Gesetz gibt. Äh so reingeschoben wurde auf den letzten Drücker, äh dass man das noch irgendwie schnell durchgepusht kriegt. Und die einzige Hoffnung, dass jetzt sein zu lassen,
ist, dass die SPD zu Besinnung kommt. Ja und das keine Ahnung, ob sie das tun oder nicht. CDU sicherlich nicht.
Oppositionen sind die Hände gebunden. Ich hab jetzt meinen Teil dazu beigetragen und hab da was geschrieben aber wie ich gestern im Gespräch mit Zevers, der sagte auch, ja wir haben,
Das ist schon klar, dass wir da heute am Bahnsteig gestanden haben und dem Zug hinterher gewunken haben, aber wenigstens hat mal jemand noch äh
gesagt, warum es falsch ist. Und in paar Jahren können wir es dann vielleicht nochmal rausholen und sagen, wie ich damals schon sagte, war das eine scheiß Idee und das sehen wir jetzt,
Immerhin haben wir das dahin gelegt. So, ein schöner Trost von meinem Kumpel da bekommen.
Auch wenn du sie nicht kritische Infrastruktur wie Krankenhäuser und der Bahn die Bahn äh den Bach runtergegangen sind.
Rahm ich mir noch ein. Das ramme ich mir noch ein. Das ist echt, ey, das werde ich, das werde ich mit der Sprühdose an die Ruinen der Krankenhäuser sprühen, die in drei Jahren mit den mit den BKA Explods gemacht werden.
Weil vielleicht kann man ja mal die Opposition äh dazu ermuntern, nochmal so einer kleinen Anfrage, die Bundesregierung mal äh um Statement zu bitten.
Ana. Ja, ja, ob das denn, ob das irgendwie Gänge gelesert ist.
Nee, äh ja was was sie denn eigentlich konkret als kritische Infrastruktur einschätzen in diesem Land.
Gibt's 'ne Verordnung, also steht im, steht im IT-Sicherheitsgesetz und es gibt dann eine Verordnung von ähm.
Die wird das Innenministerium dann rausschieben. Die müsstet eigentlich auch schon geben.
Ja aber dann muss das doch irgendwo drinstehen und willst mir erzählen, dass da Krankenhäuser nicht mit drin sind?
Ja, natürlich. Natürlich. Da, da ist alles drin, da sind Versicherungen drin.
Das sind äh da sind Versicherungen sind kritische Infrastrukturen. Ähm ich gucke mal ganz kurz, ob das Bundesamt für Bevölkerungsschutz hat hier auch kritische Infrastrukturen.
Also die Insektoren, Energieinformationstechnik und Telekommunikation, Gesundheit, Wasser, Ernährung, Transport und Verkehr, Finanz und Versicherungswesen, Stadt und Verwaltung, Medien und Kultur. Medien, wir sind kritische Infrast.
Genau. Sind wir. Dieser Podcast ist schon gefährdet.
Podcast. Ich ende.
Man könnte hier auch argumentieren, dass die Bahn mit Transport und Verkehr nichts zu tun hat. Kennt ihr Leute, die würden das glatt unterschreiben.
Ich ähm also er würde, wenn man ihm jetzt Gelegenheit geben, würde das nochmal zu sagen, dann würde er natürlich sagen, dass die die betroffenen Anzeigen äh der Bahn,
nicht betroffen waren und deswegen nicht der kritische Teil der kritischen Infrast.
Glaub er würde eher sagen nein so hab ich das ja nun gar nicht gesagt und jetzt drehen Sie mir nicht das Wort.
Das ist ja, das habe ich ihm nach der Anhörung eh gesagt, dass es ein Wortprotokoll geben wird.
Habe ich nur nochmal drauf hingewiesen. Na ja, lassen wir das.
Sollen wir mal durch jetzt, oder?
Guck mal, die Kritisverordnung. Tja, das war's. Ich ich habe so ein bisschen ähm.
Wir halten fest, CDU hat kein Interesse, die innere Sicherheit in Deutschland äh aufrechtzuerhalten.
Richtig, die wollen uns lieber ausspionieren.
Da waren alles kaputt und die Bahnen, die Krankenhäuser sind denen egal. So Leute, so sieht's nämlich aus.
Bahn und die Krankenhäuser, also ne, die kleinen die überall und die Krankenhäuser des kleinen Mannes.
Es gibt wieder negative Presseberichte für.
Ja, das war also das war das. Ich bin mal gespannt. Ich habe so ein bisschen, also es wurde ja auch eine traurige, traurige Erkenntnis.
Ich war noch nie in so einem Ausschuss.
Wie du was noch nie im Ausschuss.
Und habe dort für irgendeine Form von Veränderung gesorgt.
Ach so, du warst noch nie in einem Ausschuss, wo du vor Veränderungen gesorg.
Ja, es hat sich nicht, also es ist nie passiert, dass da die Mehrheit, also ne, dass die auf mich gehört haben. Es ist einmal so ein Änderungsantrag noch draus geworden, als ich zu dieser Steuergesetzgebung und künstliche Intelligenz was gesagt habe, dass ein Änderungsantrag daraus geworden haben die aber abgelehnt,
Ähm also SPD und äh CDU. Ähm ich würde mir natürlich echt bei diesen Dingen wünschen, dass.
Da, dass wir da noch es schaffen Unterschied zu machen. Ich weiß, also ne, die Anhörungen sind auch nicht da, damit du einen Unterschied gemacht hast, ne? Die Anhörungen sind, dann ist der Drops ja schon gelutscht
dann ist der dann ist die Formulierungshilfe ja schon vor zwei Wochen von der Regierung herabgereicht worden. Das heißt, das Ding muss so entschieden werden,
ne
Ja, da sind dann auch so die Parlament Wips äh schon lange äh unterwegs und treiben halt so ihre Abgeordneten auch zu so einem Schulterschluss so. Wir können jetzt nicht vor den Wahlen dastehen, als würden wir nichts gegen
Weißt du? Gegen kriminelle tun. Das ist doch das Ding, wo mit dem Sinn die SPD auch mal schnell eingeheckt bekommen. Aber es ist halt irgendwie so,
So prinzipienlos, ne, weil's irgendwie vollkommen diametral äh zu den Sonntagsreden ist.
Die SPD hat halt einfach irgendwie verstanden. Die die SPD versteht nicht, dass es eine Marktlücke für Politiker mit Haltung gibt.
Das haben die nicht verstanden. Das.
Was zu holen, ne?
Da haben die, die kriegen halt, sobald die irgendwie ein, ein Ansatz von Emanzipation im Rahmen dieser großen Koalition zeigen.
Kriegen die erste negative Berichterstattung darüber und dann sagen, oh.
Jetzt schreibt ihr Bild wieder schlecht. Heiß.
Vorsichtig, Vorsicht, Vorsicht, Vorsicht. Wir, wir riskieren, wir riskieren äh die Beziehung zu unserer Schwesterpartei CDU,
Ja das ist äh ich meine das ist wirklich.
Tragisch. Ich hab übrigens, das kann ich auch mal erzählen. Ich war gestern schon länger auch eingeladen von der AG Verbraucherpolitik
In der SPD. Dort war ich um dreizehn Uhr. Deswegen war das auch so ein langer Tag. Ähm, die hatten mich da eingeladen und sollte mal irgendwie über Social Boards sprechen. Da war eine Vertreterin vom Branchenverband Bitcoin und äh und ich eben als
weiß, also CC, wie auch immer, ja. Und habe dann da nochmal vorgetragen, was sicher auch schon erzählt hatte, ähm,
dem Verbraucherschutzausschuss zu den Social Bots, wo damals diese technische Folgenabschätzungsstudie da ähm,
vorgetragen wurde. Das war irgendwann Anfang dieses Jahres. Ähm.
Habe ich den im Prinzip das Gleiche nochmal erzählt, ne, mit den Fake News und mit den Social Boards, wie das einzuordnen ist und dass all das auf jeden Fall ein ähm,
Einen fruchtbaren Boden braucht, damit es funktioniert und dass diesen fruchtbaren Boden sie äh sehr gut äh,
mit mit Kompost äh äh herbeigeführt haben in den letzten Jahren und dann habe ich den mal, jetzt wo ich am Ende, wo die Augen auch immer größer, dann habe ich denen mal erzählt, wie das ja gerade beim Netz
Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz ist, ne, dass da irgendwie das BMJV ähm,
diese den Gesetzesentwurf der Zivilgesellschaft reicht und sagt, macht mal hier eine Stellungnahme bis zur Deadline so und so und einfach
Währenddessen das Gesetz weiter ändert, sodass zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo die ihre Stellungnahmen einreichen, das Gesetz schon wieder ein anderes ist, was äh.
Eine also es ist einfach so eine so eine unverschämtheit. Ja ähm dass äh die auch einfach allen einleuchtet. Das.
Ich wundere mich, dass was überhaupt legal ist.
Ich kann's machen, was du willst, kannst du offenbar, ja, also das ist von mir aus legal, ja?
Aber das ist halt einfach dann musst du dich nicht wundern,
wenn dir keiner mehr, wenn alle sagen, ich glaube lieber, dass die Regierung von oben Assid aus den Flugzeugen träufelt,
ja mit Chemtrails, ja? Äh und dass die Hillary Clinton eine Echse ist, als dass ich irgendwas glaube, was ihr sagt.
Und äh und das Gleiche, dann habe ich den auch mal hier in den Staatstrojaner, ne? Wie ihr das schüttelt, schüttelt ihr
drei Tage nach One Acryl wird das von der Regierung oben reingeschüttelt in eine STPONO Welle, die seit Jahren und Monaten besprochen wird, ja. Im letzten Moment
drückt ihr noch so ein Ding rein, so, ne? Meint doch nicht ernsthaft, dass ihr von irgendjemandem bei irgendjemandem noch Vertrauen genießt, wenn ihr so das Handwerk verrichtet so, ne? Da gucken sie ganz.
Ja, also ob das der, ob das denn alle so sehen würden. Ja, also das könnten sie sich ja nicht vorstellen, dass das alle so sehen. Na, wie habe ich gesagt, stellen sie sich mal vor, wie die Leute das sehen, die nicht mehr mit ihnen reden, um die machen sich doch Gedanken, ich komme doch wenigstens noch hierhin.
Ich mach den Scheiß doch noch. So, aber die die Leute, die irgendwie jeden Montag in in äh in Dresden rumhängen,
Und irgendwie ähm oder die Leute, die irgendwie äh hier äh Heime anzünden oder die irgendwie ähm,
Ne, irgendwie die irgendwie die, diese Fake News über Renate Kühners glauben oder die Leute, die sie für so blöd halten, dass die auf ein Social Board reinfallen und dann was anderes wählen.
Oder sie selber gar nicht mehr zur Bundesrepublik Deutschland zählen.
Habe ich auch gesagt, oder die meinen, dass das hier alles eine GmbH ist. Meinen sie denn ernsthaft,
Dass die von, was die über so eine Scheiße, wie sie hier abziehen, denken, so. Da würde ich aber ganz schnell mit aufhören,
Wenn sie die nochmal irgendwann in ihrem Leben zurück haben wollen als Wähler, weil es kann ja auch sein, dass sie die nicht haben wollen. Hm, also es fällt jetzt haben sie, also danke mal für diese klaren Worte. Sie hätten sie hätten ja diesen Eindruck nicht,
Ja gut. Aber das ist irgendwie so durch dieses Geschacher, durch solches Vorgehen,
Jetzt bist du auch noch wach geworden am Ende des Podcasts. Ne, musst du dich echt nicht wundern.
Wenn wenn die Leute, wenn die Leute sagen, klingt plausibel,
Zink flausibel mit der GmbH und dem Asset so. Äh auf jeden Fall plausibler als als das, was die mir heute und morgen erzählen.
So sieht das aus, so und das jedes Mal, wenn die eine solche Sache machen, ähm bröckeln sie ein bisschen mehr an den Glauben, den Menschen an dieses System haben, bis die irgendwann an dem Punkt sind und sagen,
Geil ey. Lass uns irgendwie so einen Donald Trump wählen. Der hat dermaßen einen an der Waffel.
Der räumt da mal richtig auf.
Der der wittert alles innerhalb kürzester Zeit in Schutt und Asche legen. Und dann gucken wir mal.
Hm, das klappt ja auch ganz gut bisher.
Thomas hat auch noch, Thomas hat ja auch noch einen Auftritt gehabt. Thomas Lohninger.
Oh ja und was für einen. Also,
Thomas, ihr wisst äh, war ja häufig schon zu Gast und ist ja unter anderem auch gerade im Bereich Netzneutralität kräftig unterwegs und jüngst äh frisch energetisiert im Kampf gegen äh Stream-On, was wir ja hier auch schon ausführlich
haben, wo sich manche schon so die Hände reiben über irgendwie günstige Daten
Tarife, weil halt Videostreams von großen Anbietern nicht mehr angerechnet werden und dann ist doch alles schön
ne? Da ist so der Eigennutz überdeckt auch schnell die die politische Sicht, das ist glaube ich an der Stelle auch sehr schwierig. Ähm
Nun äh ist es so, dass Thomas aber aktionär ist der deutschen Tele.
Weiß nicht ganz genau, wie groß sein Vermögen ist, aber eine Aktie ist es mindestens,
und das berechtigt einem Jahr bei einer Hauptversammlung einer solchen Aktiengesellschaft zu sprechen, wenn man denn nun möchte, man kann sich also da sozusagen anmelden und sagen, ich.
Das kann nicht jeder, du brauchst ein, du musst irgendwie, du brauchst nochmal so ein bisschen äh Aktienmacht, um dich da reinzuschubsen und das machen die kritischen Aktionäre.
Ja und die äh da hat er sich wahrscheinlich äh von den.
Die haben ihn den Slot, die haben ihnen den Slot zugeschanzt. Also der hat sich quasi bei den äh also.
Verband der kritischen Aktionäre.
Genau er rief mich an am ähm am Mittwoch letzte Woche und sagte ja ich habe einen Slot äh bei der Telekom Hauptversammlung
und ähm sagte dann, aber die werden, dass sie natürlich dann irgendwie nicht vor Tim Hütkes reden lassen und dann, wenn die Medien weg sind und dass er dann aber gerne auch noch ein paar Demonstranten bräuchte in Köln.
Und ähm was wir denn, was wir denn so, wer sind denn unsere Leute in Köln so? Und dann hat der Chaos-Computerclub Köln.
Nummer zehn Handelszeichen gestellt.
Wieder einmal, ja, ist ja schon das zweite Mal, dass der C4 äh da da reingrätscht bei einer Telekom Hauptversammlung
Das erste Mal war er zu Drosselkom Zeiten mit dem mit dem Protestbanner, was da von dem ähm von dem Parkhaus gegenüber von der Lanxess Arena runtergelassen wurde,
und äh ja, da haben wir die haben wir die alten Kämpfer aus dem Ruhestand geholt.
Das Team muss wieder zusammenkommen.
Die Band muss wieder spielen. So und ähm ja, die haben dann da auch noch mitgerockt.
Na ja, also bemerkenswert und wir werden jetzt
gar nicht so viel mehr darüber reden, weil arme äh zu dem Thema eigentlich schon alles gesagt, es gibt da keine nennenswerten neuen Erkenntnisse
gleich mal den Thomas nochmal einspielen und der wird dann sozusagen dieses Kapitel der Sendung einfach selber beitragen, weil ich finde, so wie er das da argumentiert hat
kann man das schon mal ganz klar vertreten. Ist jetzt auch gar nicht mal nur aus der politischen Netzneutralitätsperspektive allein. Ähm argumentiert, sondern auch quasi so mit der Brille des Aktionärs äh oder sagen wir mal äh
mit der Frage, ist denn das eigentlich so klug, was wir denn da machen.
Ist das gut vor der Company,
Ja und äh frage dann halt den Höckes, ob er denn das Memo äh nicht gelesen hat. Und ja, das äh kann man jetzt äh schöner eigentlich gar nicht äh.
Ähm.
Oder kann man das eigentlich gar nicht darlegen.
Schön ist auch vielleicht noch ähm vor, sollen wir das können wir noch vor Thomas äh Wortbeitrag sagen? Ähm,
die Vodafone hat jetzt für irgendein Giga-TV-Angebot Stream on beantragt. Und ich glaube, dass das, wenn der Telekom vielleicht auch dann irgendwann mal kurz einrasseln wird, dass sie merken, oh Shit,
Jetzt müssen wir der TE, wir müssen diese ähm Dienstleistung jetzt natürlich auch für Vodafone erbringen für unseren direkten Konkurrenten, weil sonst treten die uns in den Arsch wegen Netzneutralität. So, vielleicht war das gar nicht so eine gute Idee,
Fand ich auch einen schönen, einen schönen Treu von Vodafone. Manchmal manchmal kriegen sie es ja doch hin.
Wobei ich da jetzt wurde, Vodafone überhaupt nicht äh rausnehmen würde. Ich meine, die sind äh auch schnell mit solchen Angeboten dabei, wenn sich das irgendwie halbwegs etabliert.
Aber hören wir doch einfach mal rein, was Thomas da gesagt hat.
Genau.
So ja das war Thomas Beitrag.
Hat er aber geil gemacht. Fand ich richtig geil.
Super gemacht. Sasa, stand das League rum, gibt's nicht nur als Audio, gibt's auch als äh Videoaufzeichnung ähm,
Zwar im Anzug, aber dann trotzdem so mit der Lässigkeit eines äh Steve Jobs und wie so eine passende Frisur auf jeden Fall. Ähm.
Na ja und also vor allem.
Aber souverän. Souverän. Sehr so.
Souverän und der, also er hat die Rede vor allem gut gehalten. Also du, so eine Rede musste ja irgendwie, also ich mache das ja ungern.
Auch so Polter, weil die da einfach rumlaufen und sagen, ihr seid alle scheiße. Ne, habt ihr schon immer mal was gesagt haben wollten, auch auf so einer.
Ach so.
Nee, auf so einer Aktie Aktiennummer, ich weiß nicht, wie du das halten würdest, aber.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich in dem Rahmen auch ähm mit einer, mit einer vorbereiteten Rede gehen. Normalerweise, also normalerweise mache ich das nicht. Ich bereite, also.
Ich werde ja natürlich, ich meine, der der hat ja, man sieht ja dann ganz klar, es strategisches Ziel,
So und ähm dafür hat er sich dann auch mal einen Anzug angezogen und eine Rede gesprochen und vor allem, was man da auch feststellt, er hat halt, dass er hat die Rede halt aus deren Perspektive gehalten. Ja, die Argumente gebracht, die denen.
Die für diese Leute gel
und ähm das wird ja dann da wird ja gerne mal so äh die Augenbraue gezogen, wenn ne, so ein Dayhard-Aktivist mal äh sowas macht, ne, auf der HV redet, sich einen Anzug anzieht. Und ich denke, wie man, wenn man an diesen
Geniestreich sieht, ist es in auf jeden Fall in diesem Fall sehr zu unrecht, weil er da gut abgeräumt hat. Tolle Nummer.
Hast du gut gemacht, Thomas, kannst wieder kommen. Wir kommen jetzt zum Ende. Ja. Genug gequatscht.
Ja hier will auch nichts.
Gelingen auch keine kurzen Sendungen, ne.
Na das ist ja, also wir hätten es echt kürzer fassen können, aber ich habe diesen Staatstrainer Kram, weißt du, das Kirchen wummert dann auch irgendwann, wenn du irgendwie
den den ganzen Mist in ein paar Tagen schreibst, dann irgendwie zwei an, zwei quasi Fachgespräche, Anhörungen oder sowas, dann ist irgendwann.
Jungens Schuss.
Irgendwann ist Ende.
Dann sagen wir tschüs.
Ja und danke Klaus, sagen wir noch.
Danke Klaus haben wir noch. Tschüss. Bis bald.
Ciao ciao.